that bunny just traded in the stage for
the wrestling ring
entrance here at wrestlemania for
international recording star bad bunny
the puerto rican rapper hopped in the
ring
saturday night with damien priest to
face off against wwe superstars
the miz and john morrison
hoping to get under the grammy winner
skin miz and morrison perform their
single
hey hey hop hop alongside costume
bunnies in the ring ahead of the fight
but it was bad bunny that made an
unforgettable entrance
on an 18-wheeler truck reminiscent of
the cover of his album
el ultimo tor del mundo it didn't take
long for the singer to pull out some
impressive moves in the ring
bad bunny trying to feed off the wwe
fans here tonight
in tampa bay he shocked the wwe universe
by taking out morrison with a quote
bunny destroyer
and hitting miz with a diving crossbody
which
made the crowd go wild real
priest
[Applause]
the move landed bad bunny a huge win in
his first ever wwe match
just hours before his wrestlemania debut
the rapper sent fans into a frenzy
with this nearly nude selfie he also
posted to his feed about living out his
dream
the translated caption reads quote
tomorrow will be one of the most
important days of my life
another dream come true another dream
come true for bad bunny
his first acting role in the action
movie bullet train starring sandra
bullock and brad pitt
which is filming now here's what the
singer told et about the opportunity
i love it it's a great experience
i always wanted to you know to make
movies and act so
it's a dream come true i'm so happy i
heard
i i i was so nervous but you know i was
working with a lot of
professional people good people that
helped me
and you know helped me a lot i always
be neighbors because it's not my thing i
i
i had to i have to learn a lot and
you know practice um
but i i feel so confident
confident confident
that i can do whatever i want